Tennyson but today there is new concern
for ariana grande after she posted this
emotional string of tweets can I please
have one okay day just one please I'm so
tired please just wake me up when I'm
supposed to sing or whatever peace it's
just about being there for each other
and like helping each other through
scary times and like anxiety the 25 year
old later explained it's just been a
tough month course referencing her ex
Mac Miller's overdose I'm trying to get
back to normal and it's hard and I'm
human and tired you try not to give in
to fear because obviously that's the
whole point of being here helping Ariana
heal is her fiance SNL star Pete
Davidson last night he gave us a glimpse
inside their relationship
you bought a pet yeah we got a pig you
got a pig joke I just say like this this
girl like she was like I want a pig and
then an hour later it was just there
there you go there's your bujji pig
that's piggy small you already got a
tattoo of the pig of course and yeah I
didn't think I just kind of do that's
why you're great as a couple because she
can just summon a pig and then you can
just get a tattoo of it yeah re was
supposed to be the musical guest on SNL
premiere tomorrow night but dropped out
for quote emotional reasons Kanye West
stepped up to take her plagues
Viggo behaved himself I don't know how
the hell they met go get a Kids Choice
Awards to Calle West I'm past being
nervous but he's been on the show four
or five maybe law
and he's always been great so what else
can you expect this season on SNL well
their first host is Adam driver I'm
sorry son Batoche your promo I only did
it because I wanted to be in that sketch
Alec Baldwin will reprise his role as
the president of Trump don't we we do we
do and even though Kate MacKinnon's
contract is up this year she'll be back
there's a rumor that you're leaving
please tell us this is not true it's
false I will confirm that that's I'm not
leaving no I very much return it you
could also expect at least one new cast
member relatively unknown a go row dump
and a host of new writers but there's
one more person Leslie Jones would like
to see joining the cast this season no
no Chris Evans I already know Chris Pine
don't forget about Chris Paul in this
season couldn't be the last for the
show's longest-running cast member Kenan
Thompson the Emmy nominee is set to star
in an upcoming NBC comedy saving Larry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]